yeah walk him to this video playing a
yak off and from from the a/c a coffin
Nora wits very good blitz player some
old-time regular on the ICC very solid
opening that is playing here quite quite
uncommon is normally play more more
aggressive openings ok that's just check
just yank playing for a simple simple
chess IAM ok Knight takes he can
actually take root g one no we cannot oh
no sorry father I thought this is good
for what take on g7 I mean good like
playable not not a problem ok right
right here King detour g1 it's um just
about equal this position I guess
check ok check
hmm yeah not much going on still a
position to play let's see how should I
continue
hmm not sure where to put this annoyed I
won't ever should play a 3d form I know
it's it's putting stuff on light squares
but it's still gain space I'll do that
anyway
yeah whatever you you want to save our
Chinese playing quickly
check
I don't really understand any of that
okay so on Bishop see to what is he
going to do kingi five probably
hmm
yeah Kings you fire and this is actually
quite okay for like a [ __ ] g4s even
even embarrassing
ok
yeah you will continue to play this like
for ages even there's simply nothing
going on I can pretend to be better
because of the policy forum
check there's nothing going on really so
not much for me to to commentate
not sure is this this should be quite
okay for white at least I cannot ever
lose here so let's put all the pawns
fired once as possible now let's get to
the f6 bank regions yeah I was just
winning here I'm not quite sure what he
what he did I mean it's just ajust a
dead wrong and I'm not sure I mean this
is black i don't think black should link
vs this a 5 is a draw now if you play
almost instantly here you can lose and
this now is lost young a fiver syndrome
checks this is a draw
yeah and here g4s winning t I can I can
I can take time just improve and then
then go to the pawn here he's just
lacking one tempo yeah it should just
just did make a draw in this in this
game and this is probably the fair
result alright thanks for watching